citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for The Dark Knight to return again this
is The Dark Knight Returns part two this
is our first sequel or or continuation
this is our first part too so please
leave a comment letting us know which of
the DC any movies you like most which of
the universes you enjoy most is
Multiverse weekend so which of the
multiverses are you enjoying the most
I'm got a lot of love for this Frank
Miller where I'm not gonna lie and
remember to hit that like so I know that
you are liking these very very things
now today as we dive in there's a very
special thing about to happen we've got
a brand new shirt I haven't seen it yet
so in real time I'm gonna experience
this shirt John are you ready I am ready
I don't know if you're ready Greg showed
me this and I was like oh snap that's an
armor store so three
two one check it out koi look at this oh
shirt yes the bat verse shirt you know I
gotta say I think that was my favorite
Batman oh you heard at least two out of
three I might have to put a bail in
there okay but that's fair two out of
three favorite Batman right there not
bad and you gotta have the OG for the
shirt because the verse
the tag that's live as of right now in
the shopzeroedition.com store go check
that out conceived of by Greg and the
shop Zero edition team I I'm probably
gonna acquire one of those but before we
do remember if you want to watch the
entirety of this journey non-edited our
full experience every waking moment but
come on patreon get over there for the
front to back start to finish complete
journey and now it's time for Frank
Millers The Dark Knight Returns
several Splinter groups that formed from
the remnants of the mutant gang after
their leader was defeated by the Batman
my man seventh time how are the sons of
Batman his responsibility he didn't
create them they exist because Batman
broke up the larger gang why we didn't
want these costumed Heroes I'm so
curious what this taste kind of sound
like yeah who's the voice I see my
favorite patient is up and about just
super to see how well you're doing for
years it seemed like you didn't have a
reason to go on
I get invited on the talk show circuit
now and then must be wonderful to get to
tell your side of things I know the
world has every reason to hate me of
course
don't make me feel bad for him
crying clowns only use for violence oh
don't you do it in one of the shows oh
please no one wants to hear from me I'll
make some calls right now could you
introduce me as Joker
sure Robert De Niro's there yeah
make sure Murray's there you know I like
to keep you out of domestic affairs with
all the Ruckus you stir up yes sir
President Reagan
now I'm not asking you to put him down
not yet anyway ride him around the yard
a few times if you have to you know what
I'm asking oh what oh damn you know how
to get in touch with him don't you son
oh
geez Reagan riding around a few times
Donna Justice boy you even old enough to
drink
drink we slice our dices we prove it you
keep slicing Dice and when you're
holding guns because it's got a weird
thing with the slicing and Dyson
yeah
you're not too bright are you
whoa
the most Frank Miller designs
oh man
lady Spud nine Rob whoa I need the
points
whoa yes let's go
who is this so brutal no no you got this
ugh
look at all Nazi nips
who's kicking over this character design
and look how it's translated into
animation is so like Reagan looks like a
mix of Frank Miller and Reagan and then
she is well the most Frank Miller yeah
hey this fight is fantastic
whoa pull that trigger and I'll be back
for you
oh
Bruno's heading your way leader into the
alley do not let her see you why I like
that order and you're fired
yes oh
do not let her see you
maybe not the celebration damn it now
you're fired come on and he meant it of
course maybe he just met your five years
she's in the alley so she did her job if
you're lucky Bruno you'll end up in jail
tonight
first you're going to tell me what Joker
has planned for his TV appearance
an incredible punch line I assure you
the speed of this hack oh I would love
it if he just continued forever
Batman is the hag yeah it's Baba Yaga
well then she just like went down to
shoot it like into that hole she made
with grenades oh
[Music]
brought a kid with him
excellent timing
oh no no the blind guy
whoa
cool probably would have been easier to
grab him and move him sure but you know
but you want to make that big impression
yeah that entrance
so you have like a whole makeup designed
for this Alfred doesn't and like the
seats there and applique yeah Alfred
went to cinema makeup School
this
oh we have to talk my place in the
morning until then stay out of my way
all right like there's some respect get
that respect it's good just appointed a
new police commissioner and I'm not
about to interfere the job will
officially change hands from outgoing
Commissioner James Gordon to incoming
Ellen yendel oh yeah neither has
commented yet on Ms jindal's plans did
she come around to the Batman they do a
really good job pacing it as a part one
and part two like it feels connected but
you can watch them separate yeah and it
has that like rewarding if you did watch
part one right now you're back yeah a
man returned to the public eye who
refuses to do nothing while chaos runs
rampant now it's commissioner yandel's
turn to face this man she may make him
her enemy I wish her well interesting
speech suggestion speech about Batman my
species it's all about Batman
but this office will no longer tolerate
the actions of a criminal immediately my
speech is about Batman yes
[Music]
yes on the charges of breaking and
entering yes salt and battery and
creating a public menace I hereby issue
a warrant for the Batman's arrest
he has done those things
fight the good fight Yandel
amazing most American you have to go
back into retirement you're upsetting
too many people why do you always look
at him Majestic
oh man you act like a criminal we are
criminals Clark we always have been and
these are our symbolism animals
mine has teeth you got an eagle either
shut it down or one of these days
someone with authority is going to tell
me to come stop you when that happens
May the best man win
spoken like a true Batman that one scene
sets up things so much better than a lot
of the movies tried to yeah even with
the Americana that's so Frank Miller too
now those Soviets would like to see us
turn our tails and run but we've got to
protect our interest I mean stand up the
freedom Freudian slip we've got God on
our side or the next best thing anyway
lots of advanced weaponry and an alien
and people still love Reagan and this is
not inaccurate
whoa
whoa plant that flag run again with it
like the moon landing hmm
oh I also made you these
special filters wear them tonight and
or your nose uh I could kiss you
[Music]
who is that voice it's so disconcerting
it's so like got a texture to it yeah
it's like so silky in a disconcerting
way
animated movies are so good at making
toy man so uncomfortable yeah he'd be a
good opening villain in one of the Matt
Reeves movies oh that'd be fun yeah I'm
not waiting to find out what the Joker
is up to and you can bet Batman isn't
either neither of them is leaving here a
free man Blade Runner Vibes accelerate
Bobby Mary Uncle Joker's counting on you
oh go make them proud
oh that is toy man who is that it's
uncomfortable stay in the copter and do
not touch any of the controls if there's
any trouble just say boosters you don't
need to understand a thing that's Siri
yeah
[Music]
he can fly so cool to have it coming out
of nowhere
whoa
POV mow down
and the spotlight Batman you are under
arrest
oh damn that I felt that I always take
this moment to say a little affirmation
to myself so many forces so few Smiles
hey now no need to be nervous
Zappa's not a good psychiatrist you're
not very Observer man has lost his mind
that is about to murder he looks very
comfortable and confident do the
monologue do a tight five
whoa Jesus taking this shot yourself saw
some blood I think yeah do you bleed
whoa do something
drone babies I'm told you've killed
about 600 people that's right Conan stop
right there wow coming up to date with
Tony man and I won't have him being
harassed
I want people to get me that's why I'm
gonna kill everyone in this room I think
that's a little more insight than we had
in mind he's just trying to ease the
tension funny way to go about it
and I would know
would your guests get to keep these sure
you do whatever you want with it we got
a closet full of them
oh don't kill Conan zap is already gone
[Applause]
that's a nightmare
[Music]
[Applause]
ah Joker toxin
all the bloody fingers oh they're like
rotting in place
It's the funniest your show's ever bit
David in the crib the most he's enjoyed
it
oh really close
Ace the cloak oh
come on bats whoa
yeah
backseat Batman I like that she just
knows how to fly it it's over Joker's
gone
Lots
scores very Batman but new I like it
it's like a mix of different gears
toward
peel
she changed it to swag peel
let's do this wow
damn soups taking on all the KGB at one
time that hair of Justice look at that
pompadour man that flowing curl
[Music]
oh yeah
so terrifying a Superman was real Joker
is
hell gas
audience Kyle escorts Batman who Tangled
with police at the scene this is Selena
you never should have come back Bruce
you don't know how much the world has
changed Selena
oh no
hey put your lipstick back on
he does it presentationally yeah you
know where you are I need your help it's
very important oh no
my help I made myself pretty for you you
should say thank you thank you dang I
have a little errand for one of your
girls I think her name's Elsie she has a
date with a congressman tonight
oh yeah
[Music]
there's something I need you to do
conquerors men will you do it yes
howdy Congressman Hector Alejandro
noches has climbed out into a 40th story
ledge and is demanding a full nuclear
strike against Corto Maltese look at me
Hector what is happening in that man we
have to strike first we're the most
powerful country in the world sir please
oh no
yeah he caught the flag that's what's
important yeah it represents something
o'holleran sixth Precinct Lieutenant
this wasn't a suicide the girl upstairs
courts shut it down and bring her in
oh Lieutenant o'holleran man I heard
there was was something wrong stop that
oh my god oh let's double the Batman
oh of course duh this is
yeah God I love the disguises in this
no
no that's messed up
in a Wonder Woman get up cotton candy
Fairgrounds thousands will be there half
my friends will be there bring the wing
in close don't take the girl don't worry
well
oh man
jeez
Ugg oh
there it is great nice
free I don't mind
I trusted it was obviously good for you
free everything can go wrong
God these two don't like them do you
know why all these people are so upset
that bad man up there Bobby you know
what to do
get him mother show them your propane
accessories
oh that boy was all propane accessories
ah boy ain't right boy ain't right
in the eye
don't leave in such a rush
whoa damn
deck that kids mom
I love how the anime has like wild
motion with the gun too yeah and then
all the reflections of Chaos
let the boy go Joker
you know fall for that joker
oh that's bad you should get that look
now when you have a chance
yeah that's a good reaction in skull
cars no less
yeah
come on
[Music]
yeah yes
come out come out yes that's why I don't
Skip Leg Day nope even after all those
hops oh my God
oh my God what a way to go
ah
yes that ride is down for maintenance
[Music]
damn it Andy got extra clips it's a big
old body count in this one
thank you
and it is like very unsettling to see
Joker just get away running people down
yeah like especially nowadays like yeah
it's just a guy with a gun can do this
and this is
the tunnel of gloves that's where they
belong but kill them yeah
no more
stop it already
all the people I've murdered
I never kept count
I did I know
and I love you for it
just
it's finally here isn't it the moment we
both dreamed about
oh mama where we kill each other oh
don't tell me you're gonna fall asleep
before we finish
seems like you have an age today it's
all preserved like Keith Richards we can
still end on a high note
oh
go ahead say this has never happened to
you before
I win I made you lose control and
they'll kill you for it
oh you in hell
hahaha
that
whoa is among the hardest things I've
ever seen just completed his own neck
snap oh with no hands this is your force
a will
whoa
wow not giving a a fudge
yep not to move
that's a very Frank Miller aside
beautiful
cool nice
I never killed at least a couple cops in
that oh wait kill the Joker killed a
half a squadron a police
cops and Gotham sure like Stormtroopers
neutral Target neutral Target uh
come on kid
come on
you do feel the weight of Destruction in
this just a very violent in Frank
Miller's world yes and just like
dropping blood everywhere yeah like it's
all yeah you're like weighted
[Music]
foreign
wow that's gotta be painful yeah I bet
lasso around the bleeding wounds yeah
yeah maybe it'll uh Holden it shut
though cauterize
kill Liv he's far too stubborn to die
a casual Tuesday for Alfred the Batman
has revealed himself to be an
Advanced the governor to
put them City's disposal to hunt down
this dangerous fugitive wow
did I did attack police he and I don't
talk anymore I know everything I need to
know
damn it's probably in the Next Room
groceries now want to eat tonight
I'm going
oh you go back to the Alan Moore comic
book store
for the best office yeah that's why Jim
agrees to get the groceries
it's a man of taste the good news is
that our brave American troops were
victorious in Corto Maltese bad news is
looks like those Russians are some
mighty sore losers
what Reagan oh my God launch the nuke
and it gets out of the planet jeez
[Music]
it's okay Superman will take care of it
come on you got the soups
ah
whoa getting reports that the missile
has changed course and will now detonate
over and
cool that was really well paced yeah
that got me
[Music]
that's not good for Gotham no
oh Jeeps
A Thousand Suns
wow
it looks so emaciated now
oh
God right in on the symbol of Hope yeah
jeez
[Music]
uh
that's not good we are not in Kansas
anymore
did he re-inflate just there you see
Frank Miller thinks sunflowers are
little Sons
same radiation on the emergency
generator hasn't kicked in yeah what's
up with that Aces my Cheapo watch stop
too
an electromagnetic pulse in all
likelihood from a nuclear explosion you
don't know that oh yes you do
oh dear
Soviets detonated a cold bringer not
meant to kill us just us ever
ride a horse before yes I've never seen
a horse before yes let's go
so sweet that horse love it
yeah you really gotta figure out the
whole hip language yeah
tailbone all day we will take charge we
will kill anyone
anyone away
no listen to me I'm Batman I am going to
maintain order in Gotham City
you are going to help me these are loud
and clumsy these are the weapons of
cowards
yes where's that image
tonight we are the law tonight I am the
law
looters are gonna strip us dry we need
more cops on the street
one at a time commissioner we got a
problem cops by candlelight
oh no
utter chaos Gotham of blackout would be
so terrifying
oh well
they've been waiting
you go extinguisher lady
ow
whoa
[Music]
this is so freaking cool that horse I
love it more bad horse always
bowling
wow
nice touch with the glasses
that's true so if any of you want bruise
over your heads tomorrow start helping
yeah build don't destroy
it's okay kid it's gonna make you big
and strong
your community spirit
some of you will even argue that you
can't work together that's mine that's
fine stay tied up what is this the
Gestapo he lumps us together with
criminals shut up man
ought to be that voice actor shut up
shut up man I'm sure you're all eager to
help
[Music]
nice
come on man I'm suing good luck with
that
freaking guy
oh what are we gonna do nothing
he's too big there you go you finally
figured it out all you gotta see is him
inspiring a little social change that's
what it is
right
now no
[Music]
is this honey in there
is Mama Gordon inside
oh Backdraft
oh
oh thank God I'm glad she had to go to
the store too the impact on the weather
patterns is expected to last much longer
it's high noon in Gotham City and yet
there's no sun and it's the coldest day
of the year
nice lightning bolt earring though only
Gotham has maintained order
being led by the Batman
oh boy the only safe place is Gotham so
long as you're up to handling our other
little problem now he'll never let me
bring him in alive you do what you do
sure oh wow who are you serving there
Clark those Spangles you draw too much
attention to yourself you play it
mysterious you
have to kill what is it you want Oliver
the Schoolboy
I always knew it would come down to the
two of you someday the world's not big
enough for the both of you
yeah just come here for old time's sake
got a one-armed boner lately it's been
cold a lot yeah same same out here I
always love that character design choice
of like take she's been taking his arm
and like yeah you Green Arrow
where
um
oh no
[Music]
it's even close to fully recovered
neither is he
wowie he doesn't need a walking hospital
bed to keep his insides together
wow it does fall within my duties
gotta get my my calcium some ibuprofen's
a little sore evacuate at the downtown
slum known as Crime Alley no explanation
has been given and news coverage has
been flatly
yes
I love the way they made the tail look
at the best yeah like a beast bat big
ears on the front yeah you'll still be
weak between the consolidual sunlight
just how weak we'll see when he finds my
first surprise
but did you do like a gym sesh before
this gotta get that pump on train like
Affleck I'm trying to get the plan here
I mean
you gonna die tonight or what
I figure I will
or what I'm going with or what do not
engaged just monitor his position
[Music]
uh boy
whoa
oh my god wow
it's like a brick
foreign
damn
[Music]
careful oh God careful kid
isn't this a school night young lady
Clark ah what's up shoot let slingshot
go
we don't have to do this I'm sure we do
whoa
[Laughter]
you know what my orders are your orders
woof
oh jeez
whoa
I like how limited movement it is it's
all just like attacking with environment
like he's not able to be fast so he's
just finding every tool at his immediate
disposal yeah
it's okay buddy no no
foreign
what kind of authority is that
oh boy
ah
doesn't matter matters their world and
they won't stand for you anymore if it
isn't me it'll just be someone else who
do they send after you yeah seriously
[Music]
all right
slingshot him yes I'm so hoping for it
wow nice whoa
yeah it's on you guys
I'm getting out of here oh
you're a quick study kiddo
I love the snowfall too yeah a little
depth of field
the Superman Christopher Reed poster in
the background ah it was the coolest day
of that kid's life
[Music]
that's awesome
came in like a wrecking ball
[Music]
oh my this fight is so cool animated yes
oh
oh wow Bruce this is idiotic
I'll get the Callum for the soldiers
arrive
foreign
[Laughter]
anything good on
yes
[Music]
oh come on Oliver Redemption
is he gonna knock it with his teeth or
something
oh
what's that acid burns Superman
so cool lovely looks like an old pirate
yeah
oh no damn you
whoa
what are you doing do you want me to
kill you oh you're not going to kill me
[Music]
it wasn't easy to make Clark it took
years and cost a fortune exactly I had
both
oh yeah
the freaking silver away
heart
no
we got him they got nowhere to go uh
we'll see about that
[Music]
I love you Clark I wanted to remind you
to stay out of my way in all the years
to come in your most private moments I
want you to remember the one man who
beat you
and then nature beat him
damn
oh yeah
it's like his life force is tied to the
house yeah to the manor
don't touch him
the proceedings are underway today for
Bruce Wayne
[Music]
ladies such a good photo they still LED
with that photo though
as the Batman died with him as Wayne
Manor burned to the ground every penny
of Wayne's wealth have also disappeared
[Music]
oh
you've got some Nerf showing up here I
know who killed him damn you aha it's no
use let's go were you a friend
I think so I honestly couldn't say
sounds about right
that's a good moment
oh kiddo
hey
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes so much yes yes oh so good so
freaking good oh there's a fresh spring
under here I want our water supply set
up in one hour we ain't got forever
people sure we do
whoo
[Music]
so cool you're going to be my Army
operating in the shadows keeping Gotham
safe all right the Schoolboy found you
out it's all right I think the message
got through
you leave us alone I spent 10 years
looking for a good death this will be a
good life
sure and then later on you can mentor a
protege perhaps Terry McGinnis maybe
that's a it's an idea
[Music]
yeah bat OS
sweet that was cool tray legitimate that
was cool tray legitimate Jay Oliva
man they really did it
yeah they really made Frank Miller like
sing and animation
absolutely
so good as Batman yeah
I feel like we've heard Peter Weller
like another one of them somewhere
Michael Emerson was Joker
yeah then I forgot which is nice yeah
absolutely and he's got such a yeah just
such like an eerie softness to his voice
just an uncomfortable like Vibe at all
times yeah absolutely so soft-spoken but
powerful uh-huh and I like that like I
don't know because there are so many
iconic wild jokes on the Joker I do
appreciate that and it feels appropriate
for like a Frank Miller joint that it
should be like a little different Frank
Miller's definitely got that like he's
suited up he's he's got like the bravado
like he he reads more confident than
crazy yeah so like the using the Michael
Emerson take definitely worked for me
yeah it was definitely a different joke
I didn't feel like the Joker it felt
like Frank Miller's Joker sure which I
think it needed to yeah and all Michael
Jackson's back yay Yuri
um
man that was intense absolutely I friend
and two like so much of
you know I I had forgotten so much of
the you know main points of the story
I'd forgotten about those two demon kid
drone things all together yeah yeah at
all and and everything with Superman and
all that stuff and it's funny I mean
obviously that has inspired many a thing
but uh I thought the way too that that
whole thing went down like it's one of
those things where you're like oh yeah
we still have to resolve that like yeah
everything with the joker and everything
that has mounted up until this point all
the chaos of Batman returning but we
also have to deal with like the
government and and them wanting to track
down Batman and put an end to it and
taking Batman out of the equation yeah
like completely
and I I really I that might be my
favorite of the adaptations of the
Batman Superman fight that was a really
really cool way to tell that it felt
more brutal it felt more realistic
there's something to the suspension of
disbelief of like you have to really
suspend disbelief to think that Superman
could fight Batman yeah Batman could
like keep up yeah but in animation with
the you know the nuke with the sun with
the like there's a hundred big variables
that allowed for it yeah well I think
you know you you hear the Prospect and
you're like oh they're gonna have a fist
fight and they're like and you're like
nah the only way this fight will work is
if Batman brings a ton of other
Provisions because Superman doesn't need
all that stuff so right and Superman has
to be weakened by the planet yeah
exactly so it's like okay we gotta
launch a bunch of missiles at him and
then we gotta electrocute him and then
we got a Kryptonite him and then yeah
it's and we can only get that close
because he's that slow because he's been
drifting through space after getting
nuked in the face like it has to be that
yeah and that's what I don't feel like
other adaptations I've done accurately
sure doesn't ever feel like the stakes
have gotten to the point of anything
close to equal yeah it's like I don't
believe a wholesale that just yeah
mechanized suit is gonna be the key It's
gotta be more than just like to me it
was like okay the suit is like the the
cautionary it's the armor it's the the
safest Safeguard but it's not the weapon
but even like Iron Man couldn't find
Superman like even Batman in an iron
suit like if you're making itself ripped
that apart if he was at Power yeah and
that's whatever translated for me it was
like yeah I'm still just a guy in a suit
and that's Superman yeah 100 and so here
I thought yeah they managed to bring it
all onto a playing field and two they
had like the personal like you know you
don't spend a lot of time with their
relationship obviously like most of
their history is off screen here yeah
and based on your knowledge of you know
the Justice League and other things from
from various other comics and stuff and
so yeah to have them on this wavelength
where they're convincing each other like
they're trying to convince each other
like colleagues would yeah you know and
and
and people who do you know straddle that
line of like are we kind of friends like
you know we're in a unique position that
only we can identify with so yeah it's
like I love the way they realize the
physical Stakes but also the emotional
aspects of that and and even having it
come down to you know Batman's heart and
Superman being like wait wait wait Bruce
you don't understand like you know even
though I've been trying to kill you I
don't want you to die yeah exactly I
don't want you to die yeah and what a
great way to show the goodness of
Superman even though he's been being
evil this movie yeah like even though
he's you know leading with violence and
like being a war criminal and doing all
these things it's stopping Bruce at that
last second that shows he's still
Superman yeah and and I liked you know I
mean I think Frank Miller especially
often tends to put the Talking Heads in
and especially Reagan Era and Cold War
era you know tensions seem to kind of
flavor the periphery of a lot of his
stories or at least the ones that I've
been exposed to most directly and uh I
like the way that that too yeah it's
like it raises these strange questions
both about you know I'm sure there's
comparison to be made between like the
methods of a Batman type character
versus the methods of this of of you
know the American government in
situation and who's better the one
that's listening to his own rules or
someone that's just following orders
someone that listen to the government's
rules yeah that's the that's the
question yeah and having Superman in
that position where he's like it's their
Planet they're the author of my orders
and I thought that was like even though
it's just a small beat of the the
sequence and the conversation I'm still
like that is an interesting you know
place for Superman to be coming from and
Batman be the only one that solved the
like Gotham being safer than the rest of
the country because of the vigilanteism
because of those things juxtaposing
their embarrassment yeah fighting away
and I thought that was really cool too
finding a way to to flip that around and
because at the at the end of the first
one you're like oh the sun's a Batman
like this is this is getting out of hand
like these people are all Gonna Take The
Wrong message from this and it's only
gonna make things worse and then yeah it
comes down to like well
I've got these people at my display as
much as I yeah there's that whole you
know threat about like I didn't I didn't
choose these guys like these are you
know my my team my picks but hey they're
the ones they're willing and so if
they'll listen you know I will lead them
so in an hour and 15 minutes that movie
had Bruno First Act Joker second act
Superman third act that movie introduced
Selena Kyle that movie gave us all those
street level fights and then the big
fight that movie gave us the you know
the iconic now iconic to Todd Phillips
with the iconic talk show scene sure it
did a lot in an hour and 15 minutes it
did and it didn't feel it felt long
again it felt long ago in a good way
yeah and it didn't feel like it rushed
those iconic moments no no and and yeah
just again the way they've the way they
have realized the Frank Miller art with
some of the you know exotic images yeah
yeah and I feel like you know it's kind
of it's not like a 100 only his art
Style translation but I feel like the
way they have adapted his art style with
you know the current to this you know
Moment In Time 2012 or whatever it was
art style was really lovely the way they
pull certain panels was really nice
keeping in the spirit of all the Frank
Miller design work I'm so impressed that
Frank Miller loves his character stoic
yeah and I'm so impressed with how stoic
everyone was to be accurate to the story
about how we still cared sure like we
cared when Gordon's house blew up and
like we've met Gordon very briefly he's
always like everyone's got like that
like I'm gonna be stiff-faced and yet
everyone you're still invested in you
see Mrs Gordon like one time yeah and
you're like oh my god oh yeah and when
she shows up you're like thank God and
that's like we don't get many
interactions with any of these
characters and it's really impressive
yeah Selena getting mad at Clark like
those moments like it's very very brief
to get there but they use the time well
yeah and even Robin like you know you
don't do you get the most personal look
you just get like one scene in the
previous installment of like what her
life is like but even here like brought
so much like pluck and heart without it
feeling out of place or without it
feeling hammy or or I don't know just
like it managed to incorporate that
character in such a lovely fun way you
know for a splash of brightness but it
still felt like perfectly in line with
everything yeah like I yeah I just love
the relationship between the two of them
the way they drew like the triangle of
like her him and Alfred and uh freaking
Oliver Queen showing up I forgot all
about that arm ripped off like taking
pieces of him and he just wants a piece
back oh that was so good yeah yeah I
don't think I've read Frank Miller's
Dark Knight Returns since
97 98 I was gonna say that was a long
time I read it because it was like I'm
getting into comics and I'm looking
outside of just the ones I know like I
remember it being I read you know
Spider-Man and X-Men is what I always
bought growing up it's what I always
collected but then I think I was like
eight or nine and I was like I should
see about the big ones and I'd ask like
people that are like me now like I'd ask
people at comic stores and stuff like
what should I read and I remember Dark
Knight Returns is one of the first ones
I read to be like I read Comics not just
Spider-Man and X-Men I haven't read that
in like 20 plus years yeah but it was
cool to go back yeah absolutely like it
I I feel like this was one of those ones
that I would have checked out of the
library when I was yeah like the early
2000s yeah when I was starting to kind
of get into these things and uh uh yeah
like I I'm excited to like watch this
again and even maybe watch the full just
like one it was cool to see in pieces
and it'll be cool I'm gonna give it a
couple years and then watch it what I'll
probably do is I give a couple years
read it and then watch it all as well
that's a good idea like experience it in
the multimedium yeah because I haven't
even rewatched Guardians 3 yet I've been
so busy I want to watch I want to watch
Guardians one two and then three and I
think it'll be fun to do this with read
returns then watch oh yeah I just want
to have a set right behind you I just
wanna have a real someone I have a
nihilistic day sometimes you need it
yeah and I mean too these are like you
know again not everybody agrees with uh
Frank Miller's of perspective and he has
a strong one yeah so inherently that's
gonna cost yeah yeah but I do appreciate
that in these Landscapes because it also
is it makes it more striking it's like
okay there's there is definitely you
know a level of political commentary
going on in your first time experiencing
this movie like there's so many
different things to appreciate that you
know I'm excited to go back and be like
okay what is this actually also saying
as a Batman piece was it saying about
Batman what's it saying about society
and it's great to adapt loyally but but
have the flexibility to make a Frank
Miller Thing feel so authentic but the
medium allows for it and I I was saying
to you before I always say that you need
to adapt to not translate this is as
close to translating I think works like
this is damn near translation there are
obviously things that are flexible but
like this really worked as a mere
translation yeah yeah absolutely and uh
too I just like the the
uncomfortableness of you know it's like
I think Batman is one of those
characters where it's people debate the
philosophy and and you know whether he's
killing people or using guns and I do
like that this kind of Teeters on that
line of like yeah he's got to do a bunch
of ugly stuff and some of this certainly
does not morally you know jive with
everything and that's just part of the
mess yeah it is a mess to be a person's
best to be Batman yeah and there's no
kind of like 100 just morally excusable
version of this uh and so yeah it's it
like yeah there are a lot of people who
have died at Batman's hands yeah
certainly and you know you still have
that moment of like these are these are
clumsy these are the tools of cowards
yeah and and I believe that message even
despite the the
you know just a mess of of what it means
and is to be Batman and the fact that
yeah like there is a sort of moral
question that is not going to come to a
succinct answer like I said it's it's
Frank Miller's got a strong opinion so
whether you're worth it or not at least
you can see the take which I like yeah
yeah and this has that thing of it I
mean you know it does have that thing of
like you know you're you're that that
sentiment Zack Snyder record of like
yeah you're superhero characters are in
a realistic world aren't going to be
these Saint figures yeah and I like the
way that that is communicated through
something like this because you can have
your fun but you can also look at it and
kind of pick it apart that way and I
think Superman is another good example
of that phenomenon I agree and uh
because obviously you know you look at
Superman is such a Beacon of Hope and
freedom and truth justice America we're
taking out all these like uh airplane
carriers yeah he's just also boy just
like you know going out there fighting
the KGB and stuff like that you know
messy and uh and so you yeah like it is
a a bit of a man and like he he cradles
uh what is her actual name uh uh Robin
Robin in his arms and calls her Soldier
yeah and Soldier good soldier yeah and
so like there's those little just
pepperings of the fact that this is all
kind of tragic yeah but also you know
living in a tank and you get the plane
and yeah all the moments yeah there's
like so much cool too I wonder what
is next our our end of dcau yeah are we
doing the war or whatever
um
a question because they have like a
couple more before the end because the
the comments we're saying that we were
like right at the end of that Universe
which is crazy the end is nigh I believe
it is uh it's coming because we just did
uh we did what was the last one super
rain of the Supermen yeah and so then we
have hush and then we have Wonder Woman
Bloodlines and then there's apocalypse
War so yeah there's three left in the
AMU continuity we're working on and then
if we decide to jump into some red Sun
yeah tomorrow verse
we've only got three amu's left that's
crazy I know right yeah and I mean it's
it's almost two it's like I I like going
through the continuity but I also really
appreciate when we're taking a little
side steps take a side step out of
continuity into something else that's
isolated like this then we've got some
new ones yeah so this can be fun uh let
us know in the comments what of these
you're excited to see us see not sure
which one we're doing next in release or
watch but one of them soon and we're
approaching the present and then we'll
also go back and forth through time like
we did here to 29th third I think it's
2013 yeah so we'll play around there so
that is going to do it for I was like we
did we rap no we didn't we said we're
about to rap you know what we need one
one slash point before we go okay what
do you got more bat horse more media we
should do Batman my gas gas slam yeah
Batman in The Gaslight District Batman
goes to San Diego Comic-Con and looks
for a place to eat during Saturday rush
hour that is its own adventure and it
doesn't end well for Batman or the bat
toilet uh that said I think it's Batman
I think it is either way I know there's
a video by some kind of games
I tell you the Joker that joker gas got
nothing on Batman after a burrito tell
you what that's why it goes through so
many Robins anywhere as a cape there's a
lot of reasons about this there was so
many horrible
so much makes sense oh man oh man
you thought the ventriloquist Batman's
Ass toxin the thrillicus would talk
himself before Batman farted around now
he's got to talk to a doll Lynn messed
him up so bad that's why I have a
two-face he got hit straight with a with
a gas bomb from Batman ripped half his
face off
a lot it's a whole lot so much so much
anyway I don't know how to uh we gotta
wrap this up before before I let this
keep going in Batman goes to Chipotle
thank you for being here thank you for
thinking of our patrons thank you for
espousing the good word of comic books
let us know what you want us to watch
likes you need to comment what you
thought of Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns part one and two and um what do
you think Frank Miller listens to when
he draws we had to talk about talking
Patron so uh let us know what you think
Frank Miller's Vibes are all right much
love we'll see you soon rejection uh
before we go let's do a patron of the
day Shout
and our patron of the day is gonna be
Garth Mick Murray who is always
espousing the glory of comics and the
glory of good storytelling and the glory
of Superman and a glorious comic store
uh I believe is called Kamikaze which is
in Davis Square in good old Somerville
just outside of Boston kid uh I have not
yet attended but I vowed the next time I
went to Boston I would and so I will so
we're gonna give some love to Garth
McMurray and his beloved comic store I
love how much this man loves this store
I love how dedicated he is to it so not
only is he a loyal Patron not only is he
a man of good taste but he is a man of
local comic book shops which I respect
and appreciate so much love to carthink
Murray much love to Kamikaze and much
love too I'm sure they have some Frank
Miller books in there they have some
some sweet sweet stuff so I want to make
sure we have some comic specific love to
one of the titans of comics Frank Miller
so thank you to Garth McMurray for
speaking the good word of comic books
and for being a glorious Patron we
appreciate you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]